- Ah, you got it, all the way.
Yeah! Good job.
Get out of the studio.
This is blasphemy!
- Jack Boys!
E-A-G-L-E-S! Eagles!
♪♪♪
Welcome to
"Simms & Lefkoe," everybody.
We're not in the studio,
and we're dressed like elves.
- Hey. What up, elf?
- Good to see you.
And this: Who is this, Simms?
- This is jolly old Saint Nick.
- Show 'em who you are.
- Big reveal.
- Da-da-da!
- Oh, there he is!
We're back with the main man
himself, San Darnold
and we're here
at the Livingston Mall.
Today it's not Santa Claus.
- Look at the tape on his lip.
That's what I'm lookin' at.
- It's "Samta" Claus.
♪♪♪
- Ho, ho, ho!
- Santa, we got Joey here.
- Oh, give me a high-five, buddy. Oh, sit right here.
- Joey!
- Tell me what you want
for Christmas this year.
- A Nintendo Switch.
- Oh, that's a great game
I've heard,
from all the kids.
What do you guys want
for Christmas this year?
- I want a Puppy Surprise.
- A Puppy Surprise?
- A Nerf gun.
- A Nerf ball?
- We definitely
have a lot of those.
- We have a lot of those, right?
- We do.
- Santa, we got Stephen here.
- Ho, ho, ho, Stephen.
What do you want
for Christmas this year?
- A Saquon Barkley jersey.
- Saquon Barkley jersey?
What do you want
for Christmas this year?
- Saquon Barkley jersey.
- Saquon.
Do you watch football?
-Yeah.
- Who's your favorite team?
- Packers.
- Hey, buddy. What's your name?
- Blake.
- Blake, good to meet you.
- Ooh, I like your jersey, Blake.
- Sit right here, bud.
Oh, yeah, that's a really cool jersey you got on there.
- Yeah.
- Who's your favorite player
on the Jets?
- Sam Darnold or Jamal Adams.
- Or Jamal.
I think maybe one day you'll be
able to meet one of those guys.
Maybe next year, though.
- Santa's my cousin.
- He's your cousin?
That's cool. Good family.
Coolest name
we've had yet, Santa.
- What is it?
- Chris.
- Oh, Chris.
- I like that name, kinda.
What do you want
for Christmas this year, buddy?
- A skateboard.
- Do you like the Jets?
- Yes.
- Yeah?
So, Santa used to play football
at North Pole High School
and we want him
to throw you a pass.
- A little bit further than that.
♪♪♪
Nice catch.
- Good catch, Chris.
Santa was a little off-target.
- Yeah.
Yeah, you had to go up
and get that one, didn't you?
- We were wondering if anyone
wanted to catch passes
from Santa Claus.
[Children shouting]
- Let's see what you got, Santa.
♪♪♪
- [Cheering]
- Oh! Ho, ho!
- Santa can really throw!
♪♪♪
- Oh!
- Oh. You got it, all the way.
- Yeah!
- Good job.
- The reindeer told me
that it's time for you
to go to the bathroom.
Is it true?
- Yes, it is.
- I know. Santa's gotta go
to the bathroom.
- Santa can't hold it in.
♪♪♪
- I don't know
what happened to Santa.
But his friend came, and
I want you to meet him, OK?
I wanna introduce you
to the starting quarterback
of the New York Jets,
Sam Darnold!
[Cheering]
- High-five, buddy.
- Good game against Buffalo!
- Oh, thank you so much.
Gimme a high-five.
- Ohhh J-E-T-S!
Jets, Jets, Jets!
[Camera shutter clicking]
♪♪♪
- Samta Claus!
- Did you enjoy being an elf?
- I did. I really did.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, it was good.
You were a cute little elf,
though, real cute.
- Thanks.
- Yeah. Way to help out Santa.
- You know what?
I appreciate that.
I'm gonna take that compliment
and not even go back to ya.
One person that doesn't
like Christmas: Bill Belichick.
- Came out and said—
- How dare you say that to him?
- "Christmas comes at
an inconvenient time
right in the middle
of football season"
which is Bill Belichick to a T.
- Right.
- In fact, if he said
he liked Christmas,
I would've been disappointed.
- Well, he's a curmudgeon.
We know that.
- I can just see him, like,
pretending to open up gifts
and going, "This is great"
but, like, actually having
play calls in the gift wrapping paper.
- No, this is all just getting
in the way right now, OK?
He's tryin' to get ready
for the playoffs
and he doesn't wanna worry
about who's naughty
and who's nice.
- Do you think Bill Belichick
likes New Year's?
- Uh, well, I don't think
he cares because
as my New England friends
always joke
when the playoffs start,
they always go
"Regular season's starting
for us," which is pretty true.
- Damn. I'm so jealous
of Patriots fans.
So, that's an inconvenient time
for Bill Belichick
but I wanna talk
about inconvenient truths.
♪♪♪
I'm gonna give the team.
You tell me the inconvenient
truth about this playoff team
and what can hold them back.
- Gotcha.
- The New Orleans Saints.
I'll tell you one of
the inconvenient truths there.
- What's the excuse
they've been leaning on?
- Well, I will say this.
I think one of
the inconvenient truths
and it's been exposed
a little bit
is Drew Brees and what he can
bring to the Saints offense.
I know. We're gonna
open up a can of worms here.
- What do you want? What do
you want, Who Dat Nation?
- But we talk about offenses
all the time, right?
- Yes!
- How great offenses make you defend the whole field.
- Sure.
- But he's not— at this age,
39 years old, he's not capable
of scrambling out of the pocket,
making plays that way.
- Monday against Carolina,
when the rush got there
the play was over.
- Exactly right.
He's not gonna make
any physically demanding plays
that we're gonna go,
"Whoa, there was nobody open
the protection
wasn't that great
and he still made it happen."
And, hey, listen. He throws
the ball shorter downfield.
He's tied with Eli Manning
for 28th in football
in yards in the air.
- Intended air yards—
him and Eli tied.
- Yes, so, again, they can win the Super Bowl with him.
- Yes.
- But there is little issues
with his game
and when you see teams
take away their screens
and things like that
that offense doesn't work
as smoothly because nobody's
scared of Drew Brees
throwing bombs over their head.
- There's one team that everybody is piling on right now—
- Yeah.
- Cuz they're excited they no longer have a bye.
- Right.
- The Patriots.
- Ooh.
- I'm still scared
of the Patriots.
- Yes, you should be.
- Just gonna put that out there.
But what is their
inconvenient truth?
- Their inconvenient truth
is that Gronk
is no longer the greatest
mismatch in football.
That has ended.
- Wow.
- Gronk is no longer
holding the trophy
as the best tight end
in the game.
And I would even argue
that he's not
even Brady's go-to guy
all the time.
I think there's been big moments
during the year where he's gone
"I'm gonna go
to Josh Gordon here.
I trust him in this situation."
And since Josh Gordon's
been there, he's been targeted
more than any other receiver
on their team.
- I want a real truth.
- But yes, Gronk has lost a step.
I do think he's lost his
intensity, and I
don't think— hey, there's a reason
New England was rumored
to be trying to trade him
in the offseason.
I think they saw a few,
you know
dents in the armor here
that were about to come about.
- A few more dents in the armor.
- Yeah.
- L.A. Rams. This offense has been struggling.
- What's the inconvenient truth
about the Rams?
- People are gonna point
to Jared Goff, right?
- They are.
- Who's been in Strugglesville.
I mean, yes.
- One touchdown the last three weeks.
- It's not been perfect.
OK, I get that.
So he deserves
some of the blame
but the real inconvenient truth
is the interior part of their offensive line.
- Really?
- They got big-time issues
there, and that's really
the biggest reason you've seen
all three of their losses.
Sheldon Rankins whupped them
for the Saints, OK?
Eddie Goldman and Akiem Hicks
whupped them when the
Bears beat them, right?
- Dominated.
- Fletcher Cox and your Eagles
whupped their butt
this past week.
- I don't know how that happened.
- That's the inconvenient truth.
Now they can't win any of those
battles on the inside.
Their running game's
not working, and, of course
pressure is getting
into Goff's face
and he's not as sharp, either.
- I have one more inconvenient truth
- One more—
- And it's me to you.
- Oh, gosh.
It's inconvenient that I gotta
work with you on a daily basis.
- All right, well, now I'm not
afraid to say it anymore.
I can't believe I'm saying this.
- What?
- He's over my shoulder.
I don't think Aaron Rodgers
is the best quarterback
in the NFL anymore.
- You sound like my son Phillip,
who last week
was watching Patrick Mahomes
on Thursday night and said
"Mahomes is better than
Aaron Rodgers now, Dad."
- Look, I'm just happy
that one Simms in the family
has some sense,
but I think that Patrick Mahomes
is far and away better
than Aaron Rodgers.
- Get out of the studio.
Get out of the studio.
- We have a shrine.
- This is blasphemy!
- I think he is.
- He's the second shrine in here.
Blasphemy. Get out.
I don't even know who you are.
- I think that that should
become the primary shrine.
- Where is Adam Lefkoe? Who—
what—where did my host go?
- I'm just saying that—
- He doesn't have Tyreek Hill
he didn't have Kareem Hunt,
he doesn't have Andy Reid
he doesn't have Sammy Watkins,
he doesn't have Travis Kelce.
♪ Aaron Rodgers,
you're still the greatest ♪
♪ But even the greatest
needs help sometimes ♪
- I just— I'm not saying
he's worse than two.
- Yeah.
- I'm just sayin' he's not one.
- It's the first year—
I'm not gonna lie
I've had moments where I've—
- Say it. Say it.
- Nope. I've had moments
where I've gone
"Huh, this is getting
kinda close."
- You said, "Huh."
- I said, "Huh.
This is getting kinda close."
- Wow.
- But I'm still not gonna
give him the nod yet.
- The best part
that it was Phillip
is I can keep "Simms & Lefkoe"
and just replace you with him.
- Oh, thanks.
- I love that.
- Thanks a lot.
- Me and an eight-year-old
comin' next week.
- Hey, I'm Chris Johnson,
aka CJ2K
and you're watching
"Simms & Lefkoe."
- "Somebody & Lefkoe."
One second, one second.
All right,
just wanna make sure
Allie's not here to surprise me,
not today
because I found him
back where he should be
in his newspaper stand,
pickin' winners.
Enough losers, Allie.
Get back on track!
Chiefs-Chargers.
I'm at home, and I'm goin',
"Man, another win by Allie."
Instead of 7-2, you're now 6-3
because of Philip Rivers.
What does that do to your heart
to know that you took an L on
the hands of Philip last week?
- I think it hurts me more
that he could've been a Giant.
[Laughing]
- Right? Wow.
That's a tough one, Eli.
I'm sorry.
All right, we're goin' back
to the Chargers for this week.
- OK.
- Ravens at Chargers.
Chargers favored by 4.5.
Lamar Jackson's still goin'.
They're fightin'
for that 6 seed.
Then you got the Chargers.
They should have
Melvin Gordon back.
We don't know about
Keenan Allen
but they're fightin'
for the 1 seed right now.
- They're fightin' for the 1,
and Philip Rivers
would rather be in the
first seed than the second.
They're at home.
4.5. 4.5.
- 4.5. 4.5.
- It's a touchdown.
- Chargers.
- Mmm.
- I'm goin' with the Chargers.
- You're kinda feelin'
Philip Rivers.
- I think I'm goin' with
the home-field advantage
just about every week.
- Are you just realizing this?
- I think so.
And I like the Chargers at home.
I do.
I don't think that, um, the
Ravens are gonna travel
and go into L.A.
and beat the Chargers, no.
Philip Rivers
is not having that.
- Do you see how he went from kinda
sure to being like, "Absolutely not"?
- I had to talk myself into it.
- Yeah.
He's officially talked into it.
Allie is taking
the Chargers, -4.5
at home against the Ravens.
- He's crazy.
He's absolutely crazy.
- A lot of people are
gonna say you're crazy.
- Well, they're already
saying that.
- But you're really hot and heavy
on Baltimore right now.
- Well, I am.
- Against the Chargers.
- I am hot and heavy.
I think it's a matchup sport.
You and I talk about that
all the time, right?
Every team has their kryptonite.
I do think that
the Baltimore Ravens
are kind of the Los Angeles
Chargers' kryptonite.
The big thing is,
and this is where
I really worry
about the Chargers
you've heard me talk about
they're one of the smallest
defenses in football.
- Right.
- And their nose tackle
Damion Square,
is 290-something pounds.
That's not big in the NFL world
and especially not against
the Baltimore Ravens
who are 330, 315, 305, 320
and then 340 on the edge.
- And they are obsessed
with running the ball.
- Downhill with a Gus Edwards, who's a big back.
- Yeah.
- So that's where
they can impose their will.
They can control the clock.
And then the Lamar Jackson
element off of it
to where you start
worrying about
"Damn, they're smashin' us
in between the tackles"
and then he keeps it off edge.
- Yeah.
- So they're a very tough team,
I think, matchup-wise.
- You know that I've ride-or-died with the Eagles my entire life.
- Yes, right.
- And there is a thing
goin' on right now
whether it's Malcolm Jenkins
on the bench wearing a ski mask
or Rodney McLeod leading out
the team with ski masks.
- Yes.
- Last year, it was
the underdog masks cuz
they said we were an underdog.
Now they're the Jack Boys
which means
we're stealin' stuff.
- Whoa.
- You think you're gonna win?
We're robbin' ya.
And they're all
wearing ski masks.
- Straight-up Philly style.
- And I have some ski masks.
- I woulda wore
the dog mask last year.
- Yeah?
- I'm not wearing this, though.
- Here's my question for you.
- Yes.
- There's two games left,
one against the Texans
then they end the year
with Washington.
They need other teams to lose.
- Right.
- Should I emotionally
get into this
or is it best if I just go,
"The Eagles, it was a good run"?
- No, get into it.
I think it's time. Go ahead.
I mean, you're playing two teams
that you match up well with
at the end of the season.
- I need more. Give me more.
Why? I need more confidence.
- I don't have
a lot of confidence.
Like I said, last year,
I woulda put on the dog mask.
- I do! Nick Foles is baaack!
- Oh my gosh. Here we go.
- You know what's amazing?
Is that Carson Wentz is gonna be
traded for a first-round pick
and we're gonna have Nick Foles,
and I can't see out of this.
- That's it.
- How do I look, Simms?
- It's all about the quarterback.
- Jack Boys!
E-A-G-L-E-S! Eagles! Yes!
- You look better. It's actually an improvement.
- Thanks, bro.
- I think you should wear this
every week.
- For Simms—
- Peace out, homies.
- I'm the L-E-F-K-O-E.
- Robber...man.
- And we will holla, holla,
holla atcha later.
Oh my God.
Nick Foles, let's go.
- [Laughing] You're crazy.
♪♪♪
Santa, it was nice meeting you.
- Hey, nice meeting you.
- Yeah, be good, man.
All right.
Good luck with everything.
- Same to you.
- All right, buddy. Thank you.
- Santa's a hell of a guy.
As usual, making us look bad.